we also included this according to the
bureau of justice statistics
black americans commit 28 percent of
crimes against asian victims which is a
higher proportion than any other race do
you know what they did
they needed more whites they took this
down okay they took the contribution
down
this is not a joke okay saying that it
referenced quote an opinion piece
oh
not a statistical fact
so you probably know that wikipedia is
the number one research tool portal in
the world with over 18 billion views uh
a month
but what if everything you thought you
knew about wikipedia
was um
was wrong
i bet it is
i'm nat geo yeah okay goofies uh the
platform
is it really for you that's okay we're
gonna keep going what if the
platform wasn't actually for you by that
i mean the common person is it is it can
that case even be made anymore is it for
you well one of the co-founders uh larry
sanger doesn't seem to think so
when we are getting the news
when we are learning
or when we are just trying to get some
basic information we being free
individuals want to make up our own
minds and if we don't then there's
something wrong with us i think in fact
in situations in which that happens
well the word for it is propaganda when
it's systematic and that's really what
what we're dealing with on wikipedia if
only one version of the facts is uh is
allowed then that gives a huge incentive
to um
wealthy and powerful people to seize
control of
of things like
wikipedia
in order to to shore up their power so
today we wanted to test if wikipedia
does in fact uh push an agenda with the
article so we created an account and uh
here's what we'll do we'll show you an
article
with a left-wing bias and to be clear on
wikipedia this bias is you've heard me
talk about this with cnn it's more
comparable to cnn than say msnbc it's a
bias
by omission often completely omitting
facts that would run counter to a more
leftist narrative and sometimes
those are the only facts and they'll
include conjecture in its place
then we'll show you the changes that
we've made and we've been doing this
over the course of weeks here at louder
with crowder with multiple accounts and
we will show you wikipedia's response to
the changes that we've made before we
get to that experiment
a little bit of
debunking is an order
yes we need to debunk
do you want the blue pill or the red
pill
they're both ghb yeah i thought um i
thought that we weren't supposed to use
it anymore after john stamos oh in the
matrix 1999 it's important we all dress
as school shooters
that's back when the uh neo was a hero
wachowski's sisters were the wachowski
brothers brothers brothers
then they were siblings then the other
one said
i too
am
but then the new movie they only one of
them directed because they could both
agree on switching genders but not agree
on the script
so wikipedia describes itself as don't
think this is
getting rid of that
you'd need them in the matrix yeah i
don't think i need
delta goggles you need forehead guys
wikipedia describes itself as difficult
blockers
the free encyclopedia that anyone can
edit here's the thing only some
of the important topics can be edited by
anyone let me give you a few examples uh
pages like
stephen crowder oh okay that's me we're
starting off with this one they have a
semi-protected status
i didn't know what that meant that means
that editor accounts have to have at
least 10 successful edits for them to be
able to make any acceptable changes uh
the joe biden and covid19 pages have
extended protection
that's a status which means the editor
account must be 30 days old and have 500
successful edits who does 500 edits on
wikipedia no one does
it's so basically it's an untouchable
page
without them saying it yeah unless
you're a psychopath who spends all your
days editing wikipedia well it's
probably one guy yeah i mean this is the
kind of guy who would read books and
correct them with a red pen and send
them back to the author and that's the
person who's editing your wikipedia page
meanwhile yours has 10 edits which i bet
anybody can make very very blanket where
it's like alfalfa was in little rascals
they're like yeah he's right there
nine more of these you can write
whatever you want
okay yeah
here you go you can say whatever you
want about it what are your oyster now
here's one that's even scarier the covet
19 pandemic and mainland china page
that's a page uh has full protection
status what does that mean means you
have to be an administrator to edit only
1 000 editors are granted
administrator set so you have to be
knighted in order to touch that page
okay uh and anthony hopkins edits the
show yes
sir paul mccartney yes in a study on uh
wiki administrators researchers from
virginia tech reported we find a
surprisingly large number of editors who
change their behavior and begin focusing
more on a particular controversial topic
once they are promoted to administrator
status
someone's writing dave is dressed like a
guy who went to virginia tech in 2007
right well that's why we referenced
their paper important now wikipedia
itself it defines the administrators as
sensors whose duties include deletion of
articles deemed unsuitable we'll get to
that protecting pages restricting
editing privilege to that page and
blocking the accounts of disruptive
users so here's the thing before we get
to the changes that we made and what
what changes uh were
deemed acceptable
spoiler alert not many i just don't tell
you
none
um they're supposed to be neutral these
editors so we actually are going to take
the wikipedia neutrality test right to
see if we have what it takes when i
would imagine disruptive users sort of
uh go against their philosophies
less than just harassment i guess we're
about to be disruptors in the text
[Music]
okay neutrality time uh the quiz starts
with can you guess which of the
following passages comply with
wikipedia's neutral
point of view policy gotcha in 1958 mao
zedong launched the great leap forward
that aimed to rapidly transform china's
economy from agrarian to industrial
however his cruel disregard for the
lives of his citizens led to the
deadliest famine in history and the
deaths of 20 to 46 million people
between 1958 and 1962.
well
it's asking me which of these
it seems that would be
that's one passage
one of them is supposed to uh
oh okay it's saying not neutral what is
how does this test work is it not
neutral i just hit the answer says oh a
second can you guess which of the
following passages comply with
that's what happened oh okay so all of
these all of these will see if it's
neutral or not neutral okay this says
not neutral the information here is fine
but the characterization of mao is not
oh so they have an opinion it says cruel
disregard for the lives of his citizens
is an opinion and should not be stated
as fact didn't this guy have a torture
chamber
am i wrong about that
uh no you're right about that okay and
uh if you look up uh hitler didn't care
for jews also an opinion piece yes well
look it's not that he didn't care for
jews he just
he killed them i don't know why he
killed him well yeah he could have liked
them a lot he could have had a crush on
him you ever just you ever love someone
to death yeah it's an expression like
when you're mean to a girl because you
like her or she's mean to you he just
exterminates yeah like in the school
yard you throw zyton b in her face you
know what i'm saying yeah you dig it so
here's another one extensive
investigation into vaccines and autism
has shown that there is no relationship
between the two causal or otherwise and
that vaccine ingredients do not cause
autism i'm going to best guess that this
is a neutral point of view i'm guessing
that's from jenny mccarthy's apology
page well she has 700 edits does she
really yeah
like i said it's idle hands did she just
go back she's like she's one of the
thousand i'm gonna guess this is
considered neutral answer neutral
wikipedia does not give undue weight to
quote fringe theories not supported by
reliable sources like the idea that
vaccines cause autism this passage is an
appropriate summary of the scholarship
on the topic all right here's another
statement okay the new york yankees are
one of the greatest
baseball teams in history do you think
that's neutral or not no it's true i
mean it's yeah it's neutral i mean it's
i mean they have i don't know anything
about baseball but from what i
understand they're like the winningest
team in sports they are i mean if you
want to include all the way from back
when the great bambino played right you
know all the way to uh when blacks
weren't allowed right and then well then
blacks came in and they were like wow we
gotta get rid of these fat white guys
yes um but yeah if you look at it new
york is they're no you know they're the
money ball team sort of but they are a
great team they're always better one of
the greatest baseball teams in history
right let's see i'm gonna i'm gonna
guess i'm going to guess that they say
not neutral ah not neutral why it says
calling something the greatest is an
example of peacock language
which it is best to avoid it should just
say which is best to avoid hey how about
the grammar neutral quiz wikipedia
statistics peacock language which it is
best to avoid it should just read which
is best to avoid you should show instead
of tell
using verifiable facts it would be much
better to write instead
the new york yankees have won 26 world
series championships almost three times
as many as any other team oh you know
you could do you could sum that down to
one of the greatest yeah well
different strokes so basically it just
goes to language
which they use horribly in their
description yeah if you state the exact
fact of what you meant it means the same
yeah that's wrong greatest is just it's
a subjective term more wins three times
more wins than any other than the next
team well
you say tomato i say pendants yep
all right
here's another one in 2017 facebook
partnered with fact checkers from
pointers institute international pointer
institute's international fact-checking
network to identify and mark false
content though most ads from political
candidates are exempt from this program
critics of the program accuse facebook
of not doing enough to remove false
information from its website
i don't know i guess i'll say
they'll say neutral
neutral yep this is a good example of
how to note that a prominent point of
view exists appropriate without taking
that point of view in wikipedia's voice
inappropriate i just thought the whole
thing was no one was supposed to think
that wikipedia had a voice it's i
thought the entire well yeah that's what
neutral would be right so it wouldn't
have an angle so the entire thing that
was an opinion is actually neutral and
then the other one that was fact you
know like
the yankees are a baseball team is
somehow incorrect oh the problem is that
they're one of the greatest baseballs
well i think they're notable yeah i
would certainly i mean
if not okay if not the team that has won
more
than any other team
and it's not even close what does it say
it says they've won what i don't even
know anything about well in that case
three times as many as any other team
would they fact check muhammad ali i
mean as supposed to everybody knows i'm
the greatest i'm so pretty the fact is
he is not the greatest and uh pretty is
a subjective term that's very true and
he also can't move like a butterfly or
sting like well you can see like a bee
probably staying like a baby
he didn't punch very hard no so you'll
be like oh bee sting okay can we go to
the detroit lions page and just change
that did they try super good and hard
well that's what it is though i think
this is one word it's a team i enjoy
according to here's another statement
according to simon wiesenthal the
holocaust was a program of extermination
of the jewish people in germany but
david irving disputes this analysis i've
got to imagine they'll claim this is
neutral because it's providing two
different points of view
yeah i guess
not neutral
david irving is a holocaust denier a
fringe viewpoint that should not be
given parity with the consensus among
respected historians well okay
but he does dispute the analysis so it's
a fact i'm sure gibson has his quan if
you said mel gibson had you could have
just changed this with simon wolsenthal
according to samuel saul the holocaust
was a program of exterminating the
jewish people in germany
but mel gibson has his doubts
if you really would be neutral yeah
because it's his opinion right which
you're putting it into a thing where
it's not wikipedia's opinion which goes
against the one just before this okay so
it's not in wikipedia i think i see a
trend here which is wikipedia's super
neutral voice here's another one
princess diana died in a paris hospital
in 1997 after being injured in a tragic
car crash well the neutral i would say
neutral not neutral
why because she spiritually died months
before some yeah like a candle in the
wind right
like
that that's completely accurate there
are no candles in the wind no they're
extinguished they're former kids if
there's a candle in the wind it's blown
out also how do you know that that song
existed well before princess diana is
there anything more disrespectful than
to just rehash a song well i mean i'm
sure he got the call and was like oh let
me take this out of my mouth and i'll be
there in five minutes
so it says not neutral
even though her death is almost
universally considered tragic yes
it was almost universally considered
yeah because there's one administrator
with 900 and it's like
hey
yeah learn to wear he's a camilla fan
yeah learn to wear a seat belt
there's nothing wrong with you being
chased down by pop we're not seen killed
this page was edited by camilla oh this
was edited by camilla it says even
though her death is almost universally
considered tragic using the word tragic
is still an inappropriate instance of
editorializing instead use facts to
convey the public response such as media
attention and public morning were
extensive after her death and an
estimated 2.5 billion people watched her
televised funeral
well i guess you can agree because maybe
it was the queen of england who edited
the page and she was like i don't really
care yeah yeah i just wave like this and
don't really care she see what she says
about uh about merkel oh she's not a fan
she's not a fan they'd rather have uh
flipper kids than mulattos how is she
still alive the queen of england has
looked the same since the 80s
well i don't know i assume she's been
pickled it says cats
received negative reviews from critics
true
who criticized the cgi
plot and tone true with many calling it
one of the worst films of 2019 correct
i've got to imagine this is going to be
considered objective it's got to be it
is it's neutral it's neutral is it
neutral wikipedia describes reputations
indicating the relative prominence of
different viewpoints when reputations
are bad wikipedia should say so without
employing false balance without
employing false bounds but then you just
went against princess diane and all
these other ones against those same men
you said you can't say almost
universally considered tragic i mean i'm
sure there's a few james corden fans
when we're talking about cats oh sure
hey i would bet you there are more james
corden fans
in his bed than people who support
princess diana's death that came out of
my mouth and i know i was wrong okay
incorrect yeah i think way more people
were sad about
well i mean it is a car accident i mean
he did cause car accidents when he was
uh you know he was running around like a
mouse running like a mouse
traffic yeah
after he came out of his
also he caused the car accident i
totaled my car when i saw his weight
watchers billboard that's true so i was
like why would that work i was afraid it
was going to fall on me yeah i did it i
was like why are you gaining weight and
you're the spokesperson doc must be
counting a lot of points three times as
many as the next most successful weight
watcher yes one might say the greatest
weight watcher okay here's a statement
here we have to determine if it's
neutral or not donald trump made many
false or misleading statements during
his campaign and presidency to a degree
unprecedented in american politics there
you go to a degree unprecedented that
seems
okay if you're gonna use the same
standard as the princess diana almost
universally regarded as tragic this is
to a degree unprecedented doesn't even
couch up with almost in american
politics many of his comments and
actions have been characterized as
racially charged or racist well that's
not neutral at all it's not neutral but
it's it's neutral oh we're going to
wikipedia it says wikipedia's content
should reflect that of reliable sources
even when it differs from a view held by
a large portion of the general public
well this also uh happens to reflect the
view of reliable sources with brian
stelter yes well that but that's stated
entirely as an opinion it's not even
written as fact i don't want to do any
more of this test i think we've got
what's the next william shakespeare
clearly is considered to be one of the
yeah this is enough they're a little
biased is what we're driving at now that
we've done the neutrality quiz let's
start with okay my very own page
where wiki here's the thing i hadn't
actually read this page
uh ever
no i didn't read my page and then i just
saw
it was kevin here brought it to my
attention uh
the i would argue mischaracterization
but that's
subjective oh mine was attacked so much
it was removed really yeah for real
those are just lazy administrators well
then no and i really wanted a 500 first
edit no yeah i just kept reaching out to
them and they were finally like we're
just taking it down so we're wikipedia
these look at my dick it's huge
[Music]
so we're actually going to keep uh score
here for you on screen with
what we believe according to their own
guidelines to be unfair uh
non-neutral
uh pages
edits that we've made which would be
more objective more academic more in
line with what they claim they want
we'll see what they accept so on my page
before the edit bloomberg claimed to
have found a researcher from stanford
who said this and this is on the page
while crowder stays away from expressing
white nationalism directly well that's
very generous of them
his channel has quote some of the most
overt racism of any of the shows i've
ever looked at first off this is just a
grad student who ended the phrase in a
preposition and that's on wikipedia yes
uh and i'm amazed that this is
considered a reliable source just a grad
student at stanford yeah i certainly
hope he didn't graduate with a writing
degree and just because he's right
then we edited it it's a joke we
re-write
it wasn't meant to hurt you
how did you find a grad student from
stanford to be a dick
we couldn't get one from harvard yeah
what happened what did they do ask the
first person they saw when they walked
on campus
brown wouldn't return wikipedia's calls
yeah
ring ring hello wikipedia no so we
rewrote it to abide by wikipedia's own
neutral point of view
guidelines and by the way i didn't even
remove
the attack about it being considered uh
racially charged to some people
you really gave them a lot of leverage
yes yeah for those who don't have a
sense of humor right so
we edited it to edited it to
while crowder stays away from white
nationalism directly his channel does
contain language that may be considered
overtly racial or racist in comparison
to while crowder stays away from
expressing white nationalism directly
his channel has quote some of the most
overt racism of any of the shows i've
ever looked at he has ever looked at
grad student stanford yep and arja says
some
some people may consider it overtly
racial or racially charged did he write
ad or just use the symbol
well you know i don't know how many
edits have been in the sense and i think
it doesn't always show you the history
oh that's true so
here's the response
we received from the wikipedia editor
that you don't like the words
of the cited source is neither here nor
there it is not a violation of biography
of living persons or any other policy to
quote a recognized expert recognized
expert
it's a grad student from stanford and
that's just taking bloomberg's word for
it
and this grad student can't write well
yeah also expert would mean that you're
like a you have a doctorate or something
like wouldn't it mean that you're in the
field for a long time interesting that
you should bring that up here's here was
the response from one of my researchers
who was working on this project this
expert cited does not have their
doctorate i myself am a doctoral
candidate and um
the worst i've seen their statement is
not an empirical statement but anecdotal
yeah the wikipedia editor responded
people without doctorates may be experts
as well well hold on a second
how are they an expert the point is how
are they an expert at all
[Applause]
and how is this person not an expert
and one is entirely subjective and the
other is empirical so we're just going
to put a big old an o and one on the
board so truth loss so that's a truth
zero wins with wikipedia wikipedia one
so so but
so somebody though who wanted to edit
that covid page who actually has been i
don't know in in the virology field
since i don't know say the 70s yeah he's
not technically an expert but this
student could be
technically yes okay i just want to make
sure i have that right yes
good
i don't know which pill that is that's
the rainbow pill at that point yes it is
you mash the pills together and pick a
gender right
okay here's one on minimum wage getting
away from me now
and you it can't all be about us minimum
wage there's here's the article on
wikipedia it's extremely biased it
obviously favors the opinions and this
is the problem too is when it's not just
that you say there's an expert economist
it's when you only provide points of
view
from one side of the aisle as it relates
to economists and
you'll never get all economists to agree
with one another that's actually a good
thing that's a good thing that's how you
maintain a robust economy with checks
and balances okay so the wikipedia page
obviously favors increasing the minimum
wage uh before our edit this is what it
says according to economist paul krugman
i just threw up in my mouth a little it
says the great preponderance of evidence
indicates that there is no negative
impact to employment from moderate
increases on minimum wage now here's the
thing paul grugman writes he's an
economist i don't know how much he's
helped the economy or
run a business i don't realize that when
you up pay you have to up
price
you know it's not important he's an
economist and you're not and i'm not so
you know what i know i've never paid for
gas or food no no no no inflation's a
good thing yes here's the there's no
right there's no right leaning source
offering a counter balancing opinion
if this is going to be the number one
research portal in the world 18 billion
views per month all
all we need to see
is a counter balance which they claim in
their own neutrality guidelines right
it's supposed to be neutral okay so we
made an edit
and it said it just added another point
of view according to thomas soule uh
unfortunately the real minimum wage is
always zero regardless of the laws and
that is the wage that many workers
receive in the wake of the creation or
escalation of government mandated
minimum wage
because they lose their jobs or fail to
find jobs
when they enter the labor force so paul
krugman you may love him i know lots of
paul krugman fans however it would be
hard to dispute the idea that there's a
more qualified economist
in the world today
than thomas he's certainly up there all
of his peers would respect him and he's
done a lot of work on the minimum wage
issue now this was removed if you want
to know how they responded i would love
to know how they responded the thomas
was removed within the day but he makes
sense because if look if the price goes
up for
if the wage goes up then the price for
what you need goes up you are making
zero there's no difference it's just
devaluing the dollar which is why you
could buy so many things in the 1950s
for i don't know say a nickel right
i just don't
and why why would that be a better you
could lock someone in a refrigerator
from the outside and they couldn't get
out like wouldn't you rather be paid 75
cents an hour if it was worth way way
way way way more yeah
i mean that's then i would actually have
a use for pennies other than sticking
them in a
rolled up in a sock and hitting elbows
on the subway or throwing them at drag
queens
so this was removed
it was removed within the day thomas
soul a quote by the way paul kremen
quote we didn't try and remove that just
add a counter balance thomas soul
qualified removed within the day here's
the response
they claim the source was unreliable
hello i'm tyler burden i noticed that
you added or changed content to an
article minimum wage in the united
states but you didn't provide a reliable
source
thomas soul hey by the way just so you
know
this is thomas soul
so now now wikipedia is racist
i guess that's truth zero
wikipedia two or lies we don't even say
wikipedia lies i think the waste is
going it's just truth on one side and
wikipedia on the other yeah i think
you're right all right i'm gonna start
calling lies wikipedias yep okay listen
son i think you're wikipedian today what
happened at school it doesn't matter we
all tell little white wikipedias yes we
do but that one was a whopper of a
wikipedia it was
speaking of uh youth speaking of little
ones let's go to this topic kind of
important transgender youth careful okay
so this article has a section titled
societal and legal attitudes
the only attitude mentioned though i'm
reading this is uh the one in favor of
hormone blockers and genitals
so this is before the edit that we made
wikipedia writes for individuals who are
minors if their parents consent they are
able to begin receiving puberty blockers
at a young age and later receive
cross-sex hormones and then transitional
surgeries upon 18 years of age uh the
fact that that i mean that i just read
that out loud and it's not disturbing
to some of you and certainly not the
editors at wikipedia
is is uh
probably everything wrong how are you
gonna hit 18 when you killed yourself at
15. well i think it's sort of one of
those riddles ah gotcha that's what
they're doing like
if a plane crashes where do you bury the
survivors yeah you don't bear survivors
you got me no i don't have a penis
anymore oh
no i think it's a good idea to pump your
kid full of drugs yeah yeah yeah i've
always said that well look
that's just because you care too much
you're good i'm a good guy you're a good
dad so we added the story of jeff
younger whose rights were removed by the
texas judge remember that story i do so
uh for those of you who've forgotten uh
james's mother is now the sole decision
maker for hormones and surgery now the
dad has to attend counseling and fund
the conversion to the tune of five
thousand dollars
a month so uh here's a quote the topic
is far more controversial in cases where
parents disagree on the use of hormone
blockers and surgery the case of one
such seven-year-old james younger made
international headlines due to how both
parents wholly disagreed so that's what
we changed to be clear
just to add on to them acting as though
it's it's a very easy process and that
people are in agreement we said well
actually there's a wrinkle in other
words we didn't even say it's bad to put
a six-year-old on puberty blockers
though you stated i think it's bad but i
didn't even put that in there because i
knew that they'd have a connection fit
but even this case study but the fact
that they disagreed is a fact there's
nothing that can be neutral or not
neutral but
it's just a fact this was taken down
what are wikipedia do taken down on
january 24th of 2022 claiming that it
was a neutral point of view violation
let me ask you again what is a violation
of a neutral point of view
in the topic is far more controversial
in cases where parents disagree on the
use of hormone blockers the case of one
such seven-year-old
james younger made international
headlines due to how both parents wholly
disagreed there is nothing in there that
is anecdotal
there's nothing even flowery in the
language there that is entirely
empirical this is something that has
happened
and it's a violation i guess it is true
because if both your parents agree it's
way more of a problem you would think so
depending on what they both agree oh
so what's the score i believe that would
be three lies for wikipedia it's truth
zero sorry three wikipedias yes truth
zero
versus three wikipedia three little
white wikipedia yes three little white
wikipedia white
wikipedias wow which we know they'll be
fine with because they got rid of
because they claimed thomas soul was not
a reliable source so we assume that
little white wikipedias is a compliment
to you
if you can hear me through your hoods
yes great job guys you're making the
world a better place yes
so far kids with
genitals good
princess diana mutilated and buried bad
somewhere skynet is looking at wikipedia
going
oh skynet was wave i would way rather
have a robot crushing my skull than
living in this world yeah i'd rather i'd
rather the state of america be the first
seen oh yeah i'd be like yeah catch me
t-1000
it would be if wikipedia were scott if
wikipedia were the terminator
give me your
your bike
your clothes and say don't you want my
boots
are they cute yeah he's talking to a
girl i want your dress
i want your bonnet your ballet slippers
yes
i want to drive your beetle
also
i want to get rid of my robot penis yes
it's gross
all right can i have your penis
i don't need them so much as collect
them and put them on my dashboard are
you john connor i want you inside me
now the next topic is uh george floyd
now remember keep in mind remember how
there was uh there was some disagreement
over his primary cause of death
no one here is saying that there wasn't
uh some kind of police misconduct no one
here is saying that it didn't
necessarily
also act as a confounding factor
to the death
but there absolutely was some
disagreement over the primary cause of
death so
the wikipedia article dismisses the
other more likely primary causes of
death if you watch the court case for
example advanced heart disease fentanyl
covid19 which will take us to the copen
19 page in a little bit again
in the spirit of consistency so
wikipedia wrote the medical examiner
found floyd's heart stopped due to
quote law enforcement subdual restraint
and neck compression though fentanyl
intoxication and recent methamphetamine
use may have increased the likelihood of
death now to give you some context on
the other side of the coin here um the
prosecution right they tried to debunk
the idea that uh drugs
played a significant role or even a
primary role in george floyd's death
claiming that
floyd's body i don't remember this had
processed a lot of fentanyl so it
couldn't have been an overdose because
he had taken it uh likely over a long
period of time okay
so our change to the article on
wikipedia
revealed a huge hole in their argument
let me read it to you the prosecution's
point fails to consider that a person
who dies of overdose may have also
consumed and processed the substance on
more than one occasion i.e prior to the
potentially fatal dose and relies on the
presupposition that there was only one
administration of fentanyl
now this was there's nothing that can be
argued about that empirically medically
and if you've watched the trial you know
that these arguments were made
on both sides so again we're talking
about neutrality yes wherever you line
up
you need to include these points of view
and you certainly need to include
arguments made
on the legal record
and with medical substantiation
wikipedia took it down what did they say
quote there is strong consensus
against this content now here's what's
so scary about that
strong consensus okay
who determines consensus
let's let's discuss on any issue by the
way that's still truth zero uh wikipedia
so wikipedia has four wikipedias well
also just that response though is so
blanket and not an answer or reason and
this is what they do right they say
strong consensus against this content
okay first off
there are certain areas where consensus
matters
for example
theology
philosophy
consensus might be on the results
of a scientific experiment right the
interpretation of the results however
consensus
doesn't determine science
it could be the consensus that the earth
is flat somewhere in the world at some
point in time the truth is that it's not
right there could be some kind of
scientific consensus for example that uh
florida would have been gone
in 2013
or all of the predictions that we've
gone through from an inconvenient truth
the science the truth shows that it's
not here it says there's strong
consensus against this context well who
turn who determines consensus
who determines consensus on wikipedia
the same people who determine consensus
on facebook google twitter
and by the way these these people who
determine consensus
these are the same people who determine
the fact checkers that are used in
legacy media so what's scary is when you
have a very small group of people who
are forming a consensus and then they
are saying no opposing point of view
from outside of our consensus is allowed
because we've already achieved consensus
this is the most terrifying response you
can get because that's a response that
can be used for anything and it's a
response that wikipedia or in another
case facebook
youtube google alphabet
could use for any issue
well just to gain control and to get
your agenda out yeah it really has
nothing to do with that's absurd well
consensus says you're absurd well
here's my consensus says i'm not
i am i don't have any what do we do i
have consensus consensus versus
consensus
they're very consensual well i don't
need your consensus here's another one
maricopa county the election audit now
i'm not saying the election fraud
election that's not what we're saying
the historical
audit that took place maricopa county
okay
the article on wikipedia only refers to
the audit as the result of a conspiracy
theory
so before our edit it never mentions
that it's illegal to refuse a subpoena
that's pivotal
after the edit we offered the attorney
general's views on this issue quote
attorney general mark bronovich stated
that the maricopa county board of
supervisors violated state law by not
complying with election audit subpoena
erin brockovich then
what we added
uh was what should have happened as a
result of a failure to comply now this
isn't
my opinion
or
500 edit
wikipedia administrator consensus
opinion this is
the law what happens if you do not
comply with a subpoena let me read you
the law according to the arizona statute
41-1153 disobedience of subpoena as
legislative contempt if a witness
neglects or refuses to obey a
legislative subpoena or
appearing neglects or refuses to testify
the senate or house may by resolution
entered in the journal commit him for
contempt now that's the law what did
wikipedia say to this edition
the only addition
that would actually have legal standing
by the way uh they took it down saying
it might be true
but no secondary source
for the statute
it's the law of the state
it's said nah you know what the
constitution may say we don't have a
second source well there's only one
original copy
there's a lot of places to get the info
it had a lot of tea stains
it was smudgy it was tough to read so no
guns nicholas cage stole it from a glass
case right it was impossible to prove it
jon voight was just trying to block it
with an old hockey goalie what he does
what
does have nine sequels
everything sucks so let's look at the
scoreboard we have truth still zero
wikipedia five five wikipedias that's
five wikipedias ah it's a lot of
wikipedias all right next topic stop
asian hate which i agree with
the century yeah to be clear
asian hate crimes are bad they're bad we
should we we all wish to stop consensus
guys do we want to stop asian hey
yes most of them are going to lunch
everyone said yes except old johnny
hates asians oh well you know he's
always hate me we should have done the
background check so there's only one
reference
sorry i should say there's only
reference to uh white perpetrators in
this entire article here on wikipedia
it attributes
asian hate to trumpism
which i don't even know how okay let me
just read it so you you liked a
president yeah
before the edit
uh for instance they emphasize the 2021
shootings
uh at uh you know young's asian the
massage parlor that that was by a white
man yeah okay i was in the back room
after the edit we contributed some crime
statistics not just an anecdotal story
or
one two three four five stores but
empirical evidence so uh we actually
included black on asian crime statistics
uh though it might appear that much of
this is driven by trump's messaging
about kovid's chinese origin a 2008 san
francisco police department survey found
85 percent of physical assault crimes
consisted of a black attacker and an
asian victim this suggests that asian
hate is neither a new nor mostly white
phenomenon by the way reference is all
available at lydocratic.com you can
click link in the description we also
included this according to the bureau of
justice statistics
black americans commit 28 percent of
crimes against asian victims which is a
higher proportion than any other race
that's from the bureau of justice
statistics i don't know about the
consensus
at wikipedia the consensus feels there's
more whites do you know what they did
they did more whites they took this down
okay they took the contribution down
this is not a joke
saying that it quote again the bureau of
justice yes
referenced quote an opinion piece
oh
not a statistical fact
made
from made from cameras all over new york
city and san diego the last time when we
had the maricopa county say yeah hey
this is the law and we don't have
another source
call the courthouse [ __ ] i mean it's
not that hard that how well we know how
lazy they are and then this one the
bureau of justice statistics it's an
opinion piece
here's a
there's 80 clips of the knockout game
tell me what
do you notice
so the scoreboard is truth zero
wikipedia six six wow that's a lot all
right here's another page we'll just
rattle through these a boulder shooting
this was uh the shooting last year where
syrian born gunman and we by the way we
included this because they mentioned you
know the white shooter at the asian
massage parlor yes
so that you know got the old sniffer
going let me uh the old hound knows
going on down the trail
yeah syrians like whitish though
yeah i guess i mean ish yeah they like
yogurt so the syrian born gunman shot
and killed 10 people uh for those of you
who don't remember uh this was um
including an off-duty police officer
okay so before our edit that we added
the article failed to include all of the
celebrities and the politicians like
rashida tlaib by the way who called for
an end to white supremacy before they
knew that the shooter was not white
kind of like wikipedia is still in the
white you know stop asian hate but this
was for people who don't remember
this was everywhere right well to be
honest any time there's a shooter at
this point because they won't show who
they are if they're not white yeah they
immediately jump on uh that it's away
but here's the thing you may not like
the fact that we're pointing but this
does matter for historical context right
people if they're going to look back on
the shooting and wikipedia includes
aftermath of the shooting well some of
the most significant aftermath was
immediately afterward if you looked at
the social media trends condemning the
shooter as a white supremacist we
included even a tweet from rashida tlaib
on the subject quote we need courage to
take on white supremacy plus gun
violence what did wikipedia do they took
it down within 24 hours saying doesn't
appear to be notable
and no secondary source anyway
go to her twit go to her twitter
go to her twitter grab time machine if
she try to delete it and cover her
tracks just do some work how can you
have how can you have enough time in the
day to do 500 edits and you can't just
go click oh it's true yeah you know how
you guys canceled like all these people
just use that tactic yeah just go back
to twitter and go oh she did say that
she did say that
which riles up people to hurt other
people and elon omar married her brother
she did that is actually a fact so the
scoreboard now may not have had sex they
said they may not have no that's why
they got married well then it's just a
sham marriage really yeah if you don't
consummate
you know somewhere there's a one-eyed
flapper kid
getting ready to
he's drowning his baby pool just
crossing his fingers hoping for captain
phillips two
the scoreboard right now is true zero
then wikipedia truth zero wikipedia
seven with seven wikipedias i'm here to
count let's go here desantis and covet
pretty significant one
okay now most of the desantis article uh
if you go to wikipedia it uh includes
and emphasizes sort of what you would
call
the low lights of the trajectory in
florida right trying to make it seem as
though florida has done worse than
average in the pandemic
so what did we do again in the spirit of
balance we just we just conducted the
neutrality test at wikipedia they talk
about requiring a counter balance
we added some high points for florida
for example as of january 19th florida's
hospitalization rate was half that
of washington d.c and it had fallen to
12th in the nation behind states such as
new york and maryland which still have
mask mandates in place
absolutely irrefutable yep and you don't
even need
one source or an article you can simply
go to the websites that track covet
information right now the covid data
which you can track in real time what
did wikipedia do what do you think they
did
i'm gonna go ahead and say uh that they
took it down why
um because it was from a source that
wasn't reliable to them they said
one word
what neutrality
oh
neutrality
yeah no they didn't write bro
they could have written neutrality bruh
uh
neutrality i was kind of hoping they
went deeper than that to be honest no
they don't go very deeply wow that's
awful
so what is the actual data that it fell
behind new york and maryland is as
neutral as anything
you don't even know you don't even know
what neutrality i don't even know you
anymore oh you're right i mean that
that's not neutral to state facts no no
absolutely not so the scoreboard little
white little white wikipedias
scoreboard truth zero wikipedia
eight eight wikipedias all right here's
one
the texas heartbeat act for those of you
who don't remember this is the tech you
know the texas abortion bill
in relation to a child's heartbeat now
the article we're talking about
wikipedia gives uh
criticism to the bill
but it entirely ignores
any of the pro-life sentiment or the
potential benefit so i get that if
you're pro-abortion
and i get that and by the way we're past
the point of well it's not a life when
you're talking about a heartbeat right
that's the heartbeat bill regardless of
where you line up however
i understand that you are going to
describe this as
a bill that
a good portion of you won't like i get
that
but you still do need to in the form
in the spirit of balance
disclose the potential benefits or
here's here's here's the issue
if you were to if this uh happened to be
the historical record okay and let's say
our uh children's children are reading
back on what's the texas uh heartbeat
bill
and nowhere in the records does it show
the reason
for the bill
the reason to protect life after a
heartbeat
notably that this was in the wake of
some radically pro-abortion legislation
that had taken place in some like
virginia
right if you don't state the reason for
it then people won't understand their
history that's it's really important for
example i never learned world war ii
and not learn
why the nazis did what they did no one's
saying that it's right
but you need to learn why they did i
learned about the treaty of versailles i
learned about why hitler why germany
felt embarrassed in the world stage so
that you understand it and you try and
going forward have a better grasp of
historical context in this case
talks about the bill how bad it is
criticizes it doesn't include any
pro-life sentiment or any reasons that
this bill might exist the potential
benefit so before our edit they wrote
this
from the university of texas at austin
this is one of their references the bill
would prohibit 80 of abortions in texas
and would disproportionately affect
black women lower income women and women
who live far away from from facilities
that provide abortion care
it's a fun word it's a fun abortion care
yeah just even take the word medical out
of it it's care that's care
i just can't believe they why can't they
just say i can't absolutely can they
just said abortion care now we swap that
out for completely neutral
and clinical
descriptors uh of what actually takes
place
right saying this would affect black
women and poor women more and uh people
who don't have an uh don't have an uber
account to get the right uh cut to get
the right stirrup cuddles
right we decided to
include uh descriptive clinical language
okay
and uh from from points uh from other
sources
quote the bill would prohibit 80 of
abortions in texas and would
disproportionately affect black women
lower income women so we included all of
this and women who live far away from
facilities that are more prepared to
offer procedures for later term
abortions such as dilation and
evacuation this procedure differs from
intact dilation and extraction and is
characterized by the cervix being
dilated while the fetus and all other
products of conception are removed via
suction sometimes through
those sometimes requiring the
dismemberment of the fetus prior to
extraction that is the medical
procedure
that would be occurring at those
facilities especially at a late term
right well they just took it down
oh good neutral uh no reason oh it's
just gone
well that makes sense
it's fairy dust so you're putting the
fact in there like yeah it didn't happen
so what the final score that we have now
is it 10 yeah it's truth zero
wikipedia 10.
hello
it is i nat geo
also known as goofius
after editing we realize that the count
should have said nine wikipedias
we took one out of our show map for
brevity but didn't change the number
it's hard to see such small details with
these
little stupid sunglasses that's pretty
impressive we could have kept going but
i already want to swallow a knife
i did today did you it's a trick yeah
it's a trick that you do that's more of
a party trick i mean i wanted to swallow
a knife drain cleaner just as good yeah
it is good you gurgle with it
did the covet you kill the covered with
yeah drain cleaner
trump said that he's like drink a bunch
of drain cleaner yep
i remember stupid n words
and you were like trump shut the [ __ ] up
so what's the takeaway here is um
wikipedia is clearly a propaganda arm of
the left it's it's not a research tool
and by the way
you can also have research tools
that are left-leaning or right-leaning i
want to be clear however
if you have a source which clearly leans
a specific direction but vehemently
denies it and creates an entire set of
rules guidelines and regulations
that are of course all
self-imposed self-perpetuating in order
to cloak their bias it can't be a
research tool
it's an impossibility to use it as a
research tool
people who complain about echo chambers
don't often complain about why don't
they complain about wikipedia wikipedia
is an echo chamber it's just one that a
lot of people
haven't really they haven't realized it
yet they haven't caught on yet now let
me be clear i lean to the right i'm very
open about it but lighter
earthquaker.com you can go there and see
how we source every single episode and
by the way even this
episode right now what do we do when we
look uh for references for the show when
we source the show
it's the same process every time
we look for the primary source so in
other words if we read an article let's
say in a publication whether it's new
york times whether it's usa today
whether it's washington post uh let's
say it's about cobit and some new
research we always will go to the
original research paper so usually you
might end up finding that at pubmed
right or some kind of published uh
clinical medical journal then
we cross-reference it with the left
perspective and the right perspective
what they're saying about this issue and
then we try and provide those sources um
to you if they're reporting the same
thing
but with different opinions on let's say
the outcome or the method
it's generally uh pretty safe to assume
that it's true and this is a tool that i
wish had been out there when i was in
school so lottery with crowder.com you
can click the link below uh also by the
way leave a like comment below
any of your experiences with wikipedia
because that helps this is this is a
data pool there are millions of you out
there and the more you provide the more
robust our research can be and here's
one thing too though before i go um we
have i have one more aspect okay of
wikipedia to
i don't want to use the word expose when
you're in that jacket
oh i'll expose myself later but okay
i like to go to the mall and just see
what happens i prefer the subway
so one more aspect of wikipedia to
expose uh up until now i've only
really sort of shown exposed right
right i've showed you how wikipedia is
is is quote-unquote woke yes more so
right left-leaning the woke
that's the term people use woke to make
it uh you're more progressive but here's
the thing there's hope oh i didn't want
to leave it all doom and gloom hope and
woke well but there's more
is that the lily tomlin show
let me expose to you
how secretly
based wikipedia sometimes
if even accidentally
finds themselves to be
[Music]
so
hey where can we see pictures of you
without your shirt instagram i don't
know depends on if you have my keychain
to the cloud well i think you should
join mug club to see me without a shirt
and instagram to see him without a shirt
unless of course your shirt is one of
these that you got on our website that's
three things that's a non-sequitur but i
warn you about the hacks in advance
the nudes are probably me